[Musique]
face à
marine serrés
au
gala merkel qui appelle à voter pour son
successeur à la cdu l'union chrétienne
démocrate alors qu'il y à des élections
en fin de semaine en allemagne angela
merkel qui va quitter son poste de
chancelière après 16 ans au pouvoir
après ce règne exceptionnel et
remarquable qu'elle est donc l'héritage
que laisse angela merkel avec tout ce
soir simon shaw professeur adjoint au
département de sciences économiques de
l'université de montréal bonsoir bonsoir
madame merkel est devenue donc
chancelière en 2005 quel était l'état de
l'économie allemande à ce moment-là son
arrivée au pouvoir
en 2005 l'allemagne a été l'allemagne a
été qualifiée comme l'homme malade de
l'europe
ça veut dire que le taux de chômage
était très élevé de 11 % la croissance
était faible la ratio de dette par
rapport au pib était très élevé
si on compare ça avec la situation
d'aujourd'hui par exemple le taux de
chômage aujourd'hui est de 5 à 8 6%
avant la crise de coronas était même
inférieur à 5% et si l'on considère
simplement ces faits économiques le
bilan de merkel est clairement positif
même s'il faut dire qu'elle a clairement
bénéficié profiter des réformes de son
prédécesseur gerhard schröder qui a qui
a facilité l embauche l'essence mans
ceux des entreprises sur ma chique de
travail aussi en termes de croissance
économique le pib
l'allemagne est très fort par rapport
aux autres pays d'enhaut ces lieux vous
voyez que la croissance de l'allemagne
entre 2005 et aujourd'hui en termes de
pib par habitant était en augmentation
de 22% à
22 % d'augmentation pour l'allemagne
c'est beaucoup plus fort que le canada
les etats-unis la france le royaume-uni
par exemple
c'est un donc pour la presse explique
pourquoi
oui comment l'allemagne a fait ça donc
c'est sûr que l'allemagne est le moteur
de croissance en europe et allemagne et
payer le plus plus important des
exportateurs du monde et foncia 2
raisons pourquoi l'allemagne a réussi
c'est le cas ils possèdent une forte
industrie automobile et c'est ce qu'on
appelle en allemagne ami tchang ça veut
dire les entreprises privées de taille
moyenne et la loi n'y a prospéré en
grains en grande partie grâce à la
performance de d'exactement ce type
d'entreprises qui sont très souvent
spécialisés dans une niche de l'économie
mondiale qui produisent l'industrie la
technologie électrique
qui produisent et des outils le très
très spécialisés mais on connaît pas
forcément ces compagnies c'est pas comme
les grands joueurs se mettent sur le
marché et la deuxième raison pour que
l'allemagne a réussi à mon avis est que
l'allemagne à ce qu'on appelle une
économie sociale de marché ça veut dire
que l'accent est très souvent mis sur
l'inclusion sur le compromis entre les
travailleurs et les entreprises et
s'impliquer que l'allemagne a pu réagir
d'une façon très rapide à une série de
crises qui a marqué
le temps à partir de 2005 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui par exemple la crise
financière la crise de dettes et c est
aussi la crise trop vite elle a dirigé
il faut dire un gouvernement quand même
austère sur le plan dit des finances
publiques une gestion qu'on pourrait
qualifier de très rigoureuse
oui très rigoureuse peut-être même trop
donc il faut savoir que l'austérité
budgétaire est toujours il a toujours
été très populaire en allemagne en 2009
un gala marqué son gouvernement ils ont
introduit c'est ce qu'on appelle un
frein à l'endettement donc ça la raison
c'était que comme j'ai dit au début que
la dette était très élevé en allemagne
en 2005 et cette chute d'une branche
quand on dit en allemand c'est une loi
qui limite la nouvelle dette structurel
à 0 35% du pib ce qui vraiment pas
beaucoup donc ça limite strictement la
nouvelle si on la nouvelle dette
gouvernementale
mais selon les économistes
on pense que avec les taux d'intérêt
aussi bas qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
aurait dû peut-être emprunter pour
investir
par exemple dans l'infrastructure qui
est un des problèmes si on regarde
aujourd'hui le temps d'autant que
l'américain sa gestion de la crise
financière donc avec l'endettement de la
grèce de l'italie de l'espagne
c'est ce qui lui a valu le titre en
quelque sorte emprunté à margaret
thatcher dame de fer
oui donc c'est vrai que l c'est
forcément opposé à l'annulation de la
dette de la grèce par exemple et en
allemagne en avait beaucoup peur d'une
situation dans laquelle l'argent à notre
agent était utilisé pour les imprudences
de quelqu'un d'autre les grecs les
italiens etc
et c'est ce qu'on appelle une chose nous
nous sommes une union de la tête c'était
un mot qui été beaucoup utilisée dans le
passé donc là la logique de merkel je
pense c'était un peu après la création
de l'euro les pays du sud comme l'italie
l'espagne la grèce le portugal ils ont
beaucoup profité des taux d'intérêt très
faibles donc l on est avec un taux pret
activement identiques à ceux de
l'allemagne mais au lieu d'investir de
réformes et les économies ils ont
souvent souvent augmenter leurs dépenses
et c'est quelque chose que merkel ils
les partis conservateurs ont beaucoup
critiqué
et que les opposants de merkel les
européens du sud ont très souvent
diabolisé par exemple avec ce type de
deux jeunots
au final je pense qu'on peut dire que l
a probablement fait ce qu'elle pensait
être le mieux pour l'allemagne s'étaient
pas forcément c'est ce qui était le
mieux pour l'europe aujourd'hui on se
rend compte en allemagne où partout dans
le monde que mme merkel était une source
de sauvegarde de leadership très sobre
elle représente pour moi la stabilité et
la continuité
elle était très très fort en gestion de
crise mais peut-être pas assez fort en
innovation et ça c'est quelque chose que
le nouveau champ si lille la nouvelle
chance
vva
c'est un problème pour le nouveau
chancelier le nouvel chancellière de
réagir d'innover de créer la transition
de l'allemagne dont le
pour à l'avenir
immo shot merci beaucoup c'était très
intéressant
merci beaucoup envoient pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit